[Music]
the act of the cult
itself begins therefore with the pure
surrender of a possession
which the owner apparently without any
profit whatever to himself
pours away or lets rise up in smoke
in so doing he renounces before the
essence of his pure consciousness all
possession
and right of the property and enjoyment
thereof renounces his personality and
the return of his act into himself
and he reflects the act into the
universal or into the divine being
rather than into himself conversely
however the divine being and its
immediacy also perishes in this act
the animal sacrificed is the symbol of a
god the fruits consumed are the living
ceres and bacchus themselves in the
former die the powers of the upper law
which has blood and actual life
in the latter the powers of the lower
law that possesses in bloodless form
secret and cunning power the sacrifice
of the divine substance insofar as it is
an
act belongs to the self-conscious aspect
that this actual deed be possible the
divine being must already
have sacrificed itself in principle
this it has done by giving itself an
outer existence and has made itself into
an individual animal and into
fruit this renunciation therefore which
the divine being has already
accomplished in principle
is shown forth by the self who performs
the sacrifice
as an existent fact and for his own
consciousness
thus replacing that immediate actuality
of the divine being
by the higher actuality that is of that
of himself
for the unity which has resulted from
overcoming the singleness and separation
of the two sides is not merely a
negative fate
but has a positive significance it is
only to the abstract being of the
underworld that the sacrificial
offering is wholly surrendered and thus
the reflection of possessions and being
for self into the universal
is distinguished from the self as such
at the same time however this is only a
small part and the other act of
sacrifice is merely to the destruction
of what cannot be used and is really the
preparation for the offering of a meal
the feast that cheats the act out of its
negative significance at that first
sacrifice
the person making the offering reserves
the greatest share for his own enjoyment
from the latter sacrifice what is useful
for the same purpose
this enjoyment is the negative power
which puts an end both to the divine
being
and to the singleness and it is at the
same time the positive actuality
in which the objective existence of the
divine being
is transformed into self-conscious
existence and the self has consciousness
of its unity
with the divine being
paragraph 718 is a long
and very important in in some respects i
would say
even intellectually beautiful one
why i'm saying that i'll tell you in
just a bit it's in part because of a
responding to an analysis that i think
is is really
on point on hagel's part
and there's a lot of stuff happening in
here that we need to
trace out so
in this section which is the abstract
work of art
being finished up in this and then the
next paragraph getting us ready to move
into
the second subsection of the
second section of the religion portion
of the work
we're talking about the cult the
cultists in
german and this means a body of
worshipers
oriented around a god or gods
it's usually going to involve some
narratives it'll involve some sacred
places
it'll involve rituals it'll involve all
sorts of things
what we're really talking about in this
paragraph is sacrifice
which opera could be sacrificed this is
and i want to pause for a moment
on some terminological matters he begins
by talking about the act the handling
of the cult and we've remarked on this
many times
handling is not well translated by act
because that gives you the sense of
something
punctual rather than something repeated
something that may have an
intentionality behind it at one moment
rather than a
lasting perhaps even habitual
intentionality
and when we're talking about the cult
especially in this context as we're
going to see
we're describing something that is not
an action
done once and for all or even a repeated
action
but an intergenerational meaning
developing
action that is going on and on
using the cult as its locus
and as its mode of mediation
and reproduction so
behavior comportment ongoing
intentional action all those would be
good translations of han lung
and sacrifice you know as i just
mentioned
you could say opher right and that would
be sacrificed in a certain sense
this is referring to the action
or comportment of sacrificing
for or towards or with something
in mind alf forum right so
i think that there's a lot going on here
that's revealed
in and by the language another thing
i'll mention as well
is that he's going to use the word tun
which will also get translated
as act by miller and usually the
opposition is between
not tun and hanbong but tat and
han long the verb right
and so there's something else going on
here that we'll have to signal once we
we get there so the cult is
this unifying matrix
and what is it unifying it's certainly
unifying the
body of worship the individual human
beings who
come to it and engage in activity
or in being shaped transformed
educated within it but it's also
there not just as a training school or
you know a body of beliefs that we
should all hang out with it has an
object and its object is the divine
the god the cult is supposed to
provide a place where one encounters
the god and doesn't just encounter the
god and say oh hi god
nice nice to see you or something like
that
but has a really substantive
perhaps again transformative of the self
engagement with the god and it's
something that isn't just
once and for all you don't go to the
temple
just this one time it's something that
that is repeated if not
in the individual's history at least in
the history of the family
of the individual or the society that
the individual belongs to
remember the ethical nation is what
we're talking about here
so what's happening here
there there's a tendency to look at
ancient religion
especially if we're looking at it either
from a uh contemporary atheistic
perspective
which tends to flatten everything out
and uh religion oh that's all bad right
or if we look at it from the perspective
of
a religion that sets itself above all
the other religions and says ah these
other religions all
maybe some things good in them but
they're all basically bad right
another way that we can look at religion
and hegel does does view things this way
i mean hegel is going to say
christianity is the ultimate religion
but then he's going to go beyond
that another way of looking at religion
is to say that
look every human society develops
some religious activities concepts
behaviors narratives this is a
vital dimension of human being there's
an incredible diversity
between human beings when it comes to
what it is that they worship or
how they think things work what the
afterlife looks like
but there is this this dimension
which must correspond if not directly to
you know spiritual entities in the sense
of supernatural entities
certainly spiritual entities geistiga
right
in the sense of being things that take
up headspace
and play an important role within the
fabric
of human culture so
what is actually going on here do we do
we need to look back
at all of past history and be like look
at those stupid pagans you know they
they didn't know what they were doing
they're bringing these sacrifices in and
burning up some stuff and then you know
hanging out and getting drunk or doing
whatever else it is that they're
they're doing and they think that
they're actually like in touch with
uh aries or demeter or pick whoever you
want
we can adopt a kind of um
patronizing perspective in that way or
we can say
wow um there must have been something
there
ancient people weren't stupid right and
it wasn't just they were in the grips of
some
superstitious ideology because there are
you know people
at the time who are like yeah i'm not
participating in this and there were
criticisms of people throughout
everything as being
you know hypocrites holding things back
right even in the most religious
civilizations we see that so what's
what's actually happening here
i think it can be helpful to
think back to a previous
long exploration of religion
that took place in the
self-consciousness section
hegel called this the unhappy
consciousness
and in the unhappy consciousness there's
a basic
dynamic the human being
projects and this can be the human being
as an individual or as a member of a
group a society
projects the eternal the essential the
divine
outside of themselves and often to
a beyond which they are then trying to
relate themselves to trying to
connect back to and they try you know
take after take on this and none of them
actually
do in fact succeed in breaching
that gap that lies between them and
you know if we were just to stop here
then we'd have
a good portion of you know the later
hegelian feuerbach
whose uh analyses of of religion are
you know pretty on point for hegel but
hegel recognizes that something else is
happening in the cult and i i think you
can say that this is not just
pertaining to the ethical nation par
excellence for him
that of the helenes or greeks i think
you can see this
this dynamic in religion after religion
after religion throughout the great
world religions
and in indigenous religions as well
including those that have managed to
become world religions
like zoroastrianism or the ife religions
um or i mean you could say that uh
christianity had a
interesting success uh emerging out of
the the jewish matrix as an ethnic
religion and then
turning into a vast missionary religion
so you can say a similar thing about
buddhism can't you so the cult becomes
this place where
mediation looks like it's genuinely
possible
it looks as if we can have a
giving and taking between the worshipper
and the god that goes beyond a mere
hunger
or empty endless desire on the part of
the worshipper and basically
non-response
on the part of the god other than do
more work
more in this case there's a genuine back
and forth
something like a relationship of
hospitality we might say and you know
when you look at the vedic religion
and what some of the sacrifices are
supposed to
resemble there it's like welcoming a
guest in
right you bring the gods in and you
serve them things so that they will
actually
view you as as part of this matrix of
guest relations
so he starts the act of the cult itself
begins therefore
with the pure surrender of a possession
which the owner apparently without any
profit whatever to himself
pours away or let's rise up in smoke
what are we talking about there if you
don't know much about ancient religion
libations are pouring things out these
libations could be wine they could be
beer they could be
barley meal and milk they could be milk
and honey they could be all sorts of
things
right in this case he's going to talk
about bacchus and wine but there's
there's no
necessity that it'd be that it could
even be spilling blood
as well there's that and then there's
getting rid of property right
a possession all right let's rise up in
smoke
the holocaust originally burnt offering
so people would bring in things to the
priests in the temple
and the animal would be you know have
its throat cut or whatever else is going
on
and some or all of the animal would be
burnt up in smoke that would you know
think about greek hecatombs right
sacrificing
a hundred uh cattle
that's that's obviously not a sacrifice
you can do every day right
but they would take parts of it and they
would burn it and the smoke would go up
to zeus
who'd do whatever he's going to do i
mean ask homer
what zeus is doing with that and it
would be you know
fatty parts and things like that and
this is understood
as a renunciation as
giving something up without don't what
deaths
i give therefore you give i give in
order for you to give it's
instead i'm giving this up because i
acknowledge
you the god are something greater better
higher more holy than i and i want to
connect with you
and this is the way that i can do it so
it's a
i won't say disinterested move but um
he says in doing so he renounces before
the essence of his pure consciousness
now this is important pure consciousness
right because we're going to see later
on
well consciousness isn't always quite so
pure all possession
right eigentube and right of the
property and enjoyment thereof good news
is going to also return and the
uh renounces his personality and the
return of his act and to himself he
reflects the act into the universal
or into the divine being rather it than
into himself and this is a way to do
things and we can understand
this in many ways the widow's might
in the uh gospels the widow who gives
the tiny little bit of money that she
can she's not saying
oh i'm giving this money and god will
then shine upon me
that's not the point in doing it she
thinks well i'm gonna i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna give it up for god
as we say people do this all the time
with money with possessions with
enjoyment with enduring pain
with enduring you know their
people in relationships or co-workers or
stuff like that
so there's this giving on the part of
the worshipper
that is really central here
now he says conversely so there's going
to be a
counter movement the divine being
in its immediacy also perishes
in this act there's a double movement
here
this is very interesting going on so
first hegel says
all right you know the sac the sacrifice
or the worshiper is sacrificing for
example an animal
or fruits in this case which would
include grain he's talking about
ceres and bacchus right we get the word
cereal from
ceres and baking alien from from bacchus
bread and bread and wine right is this a
reference to the
christian eucharist no not necessarily
it's not
it's not as if christians were the only
people to sacrifice
uh grain products and uh
wine or anything like that
many people do this all over the place
it varies
uh what what it is and then there's
animals right and hegel makes a
differentiation here he says
the animal sacrifice is the symbol of a
god so
you don't just sacrifice any animal you
don't just go around as well there's
a lizard i'll take that you sacrifice
the animals that have been
prescribed in a certain way
for that that god and the fruits
consumed are
the living ceres and bacchus themselves
consumed
now here we get to an interesting point
consumed by what consumed by the
sacrifice
here's where we need to remind ourselves
of the nature
of ancient sacrifices
priests would take the
devoted animal the devoted
grains wine uh whatever else is being
provided there
and then they would kind of divvy things
out so
when you have a hecatom let's take you
know one of the the great examples of
classical antiquity
that isn't just taking a hundred cattle
cutting them up and burning the whole
thing on the altar to go up to the gods
whether it be zeus or poseidon or
whoever else
most of the animal is actually going to
be
set aside for human consumption this is
why people
especially poor people loved when
sacrifices happened
because the rich people didn't just to
didn't get to
just keep all the nice meat to
themselves that it was
shared right you might not only get a
morsel or something like that but that's
better than nothing ain't it
and other things you know might be
devoted to the
use of the priests themselves right and
so there's kind of this this
division that's going on and a
re-sharing so when the worshipers
are consuming the bread and the wine
they are
consuming the god
sirius and and bacchus right demeter and
um dionysus so she he goes on and says
in the former die
the powers of the upper law which has
blood and actual life but in the latter
namely the living series in bacchus
itself
the powers of the lower law that possess
in bloodless form
secret and cunning power so
there's more going on here than just
that though here comes the second aspect
the sacrifice of the divine substance
insofar as it is an act belongs to the
self-conscious
aspect that this actual deed be possible
the divine being must already have
sacrificed itself
in principle so there's
symbolization and embodiment we could
say like a
you know punctual thing i symbolize now
or i always symbolize
and then there's this sacrifice the auf
operon
of the divine substance
in the very provision in the very
connection
to what one looked at as one's property
that one is giving away without
enjoyment
that was already the gods and indeed
in a certain way the god the bread the
wine the animal that you
have and that you decide to renounce
already belongs to the god already is
the god
in a certain way allowing you to
sacrifice the god
or a gift of the god to the god to
return it
back rather than looking at it as oh
this is just my thing that i'm
estranging from myself so there's a
shift in perspective that's going on
here
now i mentioned lexically
these these two terms deed and act
right and this are tun not tat
which is what hegel more often uses
tun is the do-wing so
this again shows something more
like han lung right a continual
process rather than a punctual thing
although it's not to say it couldn't be
initiated
by some primaval the god did this at
this point in time therefore we use this
animal for this god
already accomplished in principle so
this the the divine being has already
sacrificed themself
in the past in a mythical past we could
say
is shown forth by the self who performs
the sacrifice
as an existent fact and for his own
consciousness
so we return to the side of the
worshipper and what's going on for them
this is a way of relating themselves to
an agency a divine agency
that is already in action and that
precedes one's own
action doesn't just return
in response but has already responded
long ago to you before you were even
born into the religious community
and initiated into it so he goes on and
he says
this replaces that immediate actuality
of the divine being
by the higher actuality that of oneself
the unity which has resulted from
overcoming the singleness and separation
of the two sides
is not merely a negative fate but has a
positive
significance now here's where it gets
really interesting
what god is this referring to
a little bit later on in the next
section
and the the section after that we're
going to have the divine pantheon
here though what does he talk about he
says
it is only to the abstract being of the
underworld that the sacrificial offering
is holy surrendered
thus the reflection of possessions and
being for
itself into the universal is
distinguished from the self
as such
so we have a we have a bit of a problem
here
and it's a two-sided problem actually
the god that is being
sacrificed sacrificed to
turns out to be the abstract god of the
underworld rather than apollo rather
than
ceres rather than athena right
or pick whoever else you want on the
side of the participant the worshiper
the sacrificer the entry
into communion can also include
holding a bit back he doesn't use the
words
hypocrisy here but i think we could say
that there is
this danger of hypocrisy at this point
so hegel goes on and says
at the same time this is only a small
part
and the other act of sacrifice is merely
the destruction of what cannot be used
now we're in a
we're in bad shape in religion when
people instead of giving of their first
fruits giving of the best they say
uh what can i give the gods this crappy
stuff over here that i don't actually
need i'll give them that
and then life goes on as normal that's
how religion starts to wither and die
and turn into something that does in
fact conform to the stereotypes
of it by those who are are critics of
religion so he says
the destruction of what cannot be used
and is really the preparation of the
offering for a meal the feast
that cheats the act out of its negative
significance so what's the negative
significance this renunciation if you're
giving because you're like
i'm going to sacrifice a bowline man i
can't wait to eat those
ribs or that liver well actually i think
the liver would get burned and go up to
zeus if i remember right but pick
whatever else you want you know
can't wait to to have those uh stakes or
something like that well you're not
really in the right frame of mind at
that point
right you're not really sacrificing to
the god you're more like
arranging a feast which isn't a bad
thing
but isn't quite the same thing as a
religious cultist so he says
at that first sacrifice the person
making the offering
reserves the greatest share for his own
enjoyment and from the latter sacrifice
what is useful
for the same purpose what's the
the first sacrifice is the animal and
then the the other one is the fruits and
the grain
if you're depriving the god if you're
not actually sacrificing
then in a certain way you're being
stingy and you're using the god's gift
to the detriment of the communion with
the god
so he goes on and he says this enjoyment
is the negative power which puts an
end both to the divine being and to the
singleness the worshiper
and it is at the same time the positive
actuality in which the objective
existence of the divine being is
transformed into self-conscious
existence
and the self has consciousness of its
unity with the divine being
so now this is interesting right this
enjoyment has has two sides it could be
an enjoyment of genuine
communion that breaks through or it
could be
the stingy enjoyment of getting my kicks
in which case you've got a negative here
so there is still a potentiality within
the cult of a positive actuality
in which the objective existence of the
divine being on the side of the divine
being not on the side of the worshipper
is transformed into self-conscious
existence that god
enters into communion with the worshiper
rather than the worshiper simply with
the
static available god
right hegel is describing here
as i pointed out something this is a
very beautiful analysis
of what goes on
in ancient religions and why
people might engage in this seemingly
irrational practice of depriving
themselves
not only of enjoyment but even their own
property or their possession their
besits
right um why do they do that well it's
it's within the locus
of the cultists which provides the
possibility
not only of mediation but of communion
at that stage of consciousness
you